hello everyone and welcome my name is
tyrone smith and i'm one of the
contestants for the 2015 gore district
ambassador competition now before the
night gets heated up I wanted to give
you the chance to get to know me and my
family a little bitter I've been married
to my wife Kirsty for just over one year
now and together we've been blessed with
three loud cheeky little voice liam is
seven Luca three and Adam is not far one
I work in the banking industry for
Westpac my family and I have recently
relocated from Christchurch to work
rather than me tell you what girl means
to me and my family we've decided that
will show you instead
love
these days out on a mission to find out
in a piece make it everlasting sewn up
Lee is easy with you as long as we're
together there's no babe
we r view this as you may have noticed
from the video it's not the world class
events like the golden guitars or the
moonshine festival that make us love it
here being a young family with three
children it's all about the community
and the things that offers but above all
else it's about the lifestyle
fisheye
ok